Gregg Shila and the community relations
director here at binds a noble
Georgetown and we thank you for joining
us for tonight's discussion four years
and even decades parents have exclaimed
to their children to get away from that
TV you spend too much time on the
Internet and of course you'll get
nothing out of life playing video games
could all this parental wisdom be
totally wrong so drawing from fields as
diverse as neuroscience economics and
literary theory tonight's guest Steven
Johnson argues that the junk culture we
are so eager to dismiss is in fact
making us more intelligent
after reading tonight's featured book
you may never complain or question the
value of television Playstation or Xbox
ever again Steven Jackson is the author
of The New York Times bestseller mine
wide open and is the co-founder of the
online magazine feed he also writes the
emerging technology column for discover
as well as contributing editor of Wired
here to discuss his new book titled
everything bad is good for you please
welcome Steven Johnson yes it's true
15 year olds all over the country are
going to be sending me small bills and
checks to thank me for this book thank
you for coming out and thank you c-span
audience for for being here I like the
idea of people watching c-span who maybe
turn it on and they were watching
somebody do a filibuster and all of a
sudden there's a guy talking about why
video games are good for your brain it's
gonna be quite a change for them but
hopefully they'll enjoy it what I'm
going to do today I'm not going to read
because you know I find particularly
nonfiction reading is the last thing
people come to hear so what I'm going to
do is it's talk for a bit and there are
a couple little quick quotes and
passages that I'll read just for
entertainment value maybe in funny
accents or something like that and then
and I'll try to give you a walk through
what the argument actually is in this
book
and then and then we can open up for
discussion which there tends to be with
this topic as you might imagine people
feel very strongly interesting I've
never written a book before on a topic
about which people had already formed
strong opinions they wrote a book about
neuroscience and I wrote a book called
emergence the subtitle of which was the
connected lives of amps brain cities and
software some of you may have read it
but what I would tell people about that
they would say you know amps and what
you know they'd have no idea what I was
talking about
whereas this book instantly you know
when I would describe it to people on an
airplane or you know over coffee
somewhere they were ready to go either
agreeing or disagreeing but they had a
lot of strong feelings about it so it's
fun to be out here with actual like
finished book ready to ready to have
people read it and respond we did a
excerpt of the television section that I
ran on the New York Times magazine about
three weeks ago and so that sent off you
know the internet went kind of crazy
with that and so it's a weird point
where there's this whole existing debate
about the book that seems to be going on
online and the blogs and everywhere
but most people haven't read it because
it only came out on Thursday or Friday
so it's it's there's a high ratio of
discussion to actual reading of the book
right now which hopefully some of you
will will help balance out by actually
reading it I want to talk a little bit
about how I came to write it and then
and then walk through the argument and
basically to give you the argument a
nutshell before I backtrack a little bit
I'm trying to intervene in the debate
we've been having in this country about
the state of popular culture which over
the last few years has kind of erupted
into the discussion about you know Janet
Jackson and the Superbowl and rap music
and and The Sopranos and violence and
all these questions and then the FCC
cracking down on obscenity and and it
feels to me a little bit like right now
the state of the debate is you know
there's two sides one side thinks that
the pop culture is so bad that the
federal government needs to intervene to
kind of clean things up and the other
side just thinks that it's you know
really really bad and that's you know
that's the polarity that we have and
what I'm trying to do in this book is to
say you know yes there may be legitimate
questions to ask about the role of
violence in popular media and there you
know some of us may feel there's too
much sex or too much obscenity
but that's not the whole story and in
fact if you look at at pop culture from
another angle the angle that I that I
try and describe in the book if you look
at it in terms of the the kind of mental
work you have to do to make sense of a
television show or to make sense of a
videogame or kind of deal with
interactive media the kind of
problem-solving you have to do the
amount of kind of focus and patient and
kind of intellectual exercise you have
to kind of work through that on average
over the last thirty years the popular
culture has grown more complicated not
less complicated and I call that trend
over the last 30 years the sleeper curve
after this great classic scene that some
of you may know from the Woody Allen
movie sleeper which involves Woody Allen
playing this kind of health food store
owner from the 1970s who suddenly jumps
forward 200 years and wakes up and it's
20 17 21 73 and all the scientists who
are analyzing him are confused because
he keeps asking for you know Tiger's
milk and organic wheat germ and things
like that and they say well what is he
why is he asking for this and they say
oh those were the charmed substances
that were once thought to contain life
preserving properties and then they said
what he doesn't want hot fudge or
cheeseburgers or all the things we now
know that are really good for you and so
basically that you know they concede is
that all the things that we're supposed
to be so so much cognitive junk food
actually end up you know when you look
at it from this angle which I hope to
persuade you of and I've turned out to
be a lot more nourishing than we thought
so that's the sleeper curve that's the
argument of everything that is good for
you I I just want to backtrack and
actually talk about something that I've
never talked about before but it's one
of my favorite little parts in the book
which comes at the very beginning which
is this kind of memory I have of being
nine years old and going through this
extremely obsessive phase in my life I'm
from DC and my parents are here so they
can testify to how crazy this faith was
of my life where I got extremely into
these dice baseball games does anybody
remember these think they were coming
before computer games you know you
didn't have computers you didn't have
PCs but it was it was a bit like
Dungeons & Dragons for those of you who
lost years to playing Dungeons & Dragons
except you were doing a sports
simulation
and the idea was that you somebody had
come up with kind of mathematical models
of all the baseball players out there
this is what you know video game
baseball games do behind the scenes now
and you would pick out your lineup and
decide the strategy you know who was
going to pitch for you and whether
you're going to bunt when you had
somebody on first base and if you were
going to put in a substitute player and
then you would roll a you know three
dice or something like that and consult
some charts and figure out based on the
players and their statistics what had
happened and it was just ground out to
first base or a single to left field and
the runner from third scored or got
thrown out and you would do this but it
it sounds kind of in the abstract like
something you could imagine a
nine-year-old being into because you
know nine year olds like baseball and
who wouldn't want to you know manage a
team but the games themselves actually
turned out to be incredibly complicated
and the first one I played was a game
called a PBA baseball app'
baseball which was actually the simplest
of the bunch and I went on this kind of
jag over about two or three years where
I started to come seek out ever more
complicated games that would it would
more mathematically accurately model the
game of baseball and eventually I got so
kind of hooked on this that I started
designing my own because the existing
games weren't accurate enough and I
don't think I had as many friends during
that period as I might have if I had not
been in my room play these games all the
time but but I went back actually thanks
to eBay
a few years ago as I was starting to
kind of prepare for this book and I and
I and I ordered all these games online
and I hadn't seen them for you know over
20 years and it was amazing you know
pristine kind of sense-memory getting
these things in the mail and you'd open
them up and they kind of smelled like
1979 in addition to bringing back all
these memories and I started looking
through them and realized that they were
incredibly complicated in terms of you
know what you actually had to do as a 9
or 10 year old to kind of figure out
whether it was a single to left field or
whether the Runner was thrown out at
first and so in the book I talked a
little bit about this experience and
then I quote from just briefly and if
this is if this sounds mind-numbingly
boring to hear read that's the point
this is from the chart of the simplest
of the games right so if you if you this
is the instruction if you were if you
were pitching
with the bases empty this is a little
excerpt of the guide for how you had it
how you figured out what the correct
result was in the game the hitting
numbers under which lines appear may be
altered according to the grade of the
pitcher against whom the team is batting
always observe the grade of the pitcher
and look for possible changes of those
numbers which are underlined no change
always refers back to the D or left
column and always means a base hit
against grade D pitchers there is never
any change the left-hand column only is
used when a pitcher is withdrawn from
the game make note of the grade of the
pitcher who relieves them if it's great
is different a different column must be
referred to when the underlined numbers
come up certain players may have the
numbers 7 8 or 11 in the second columns
of their cards when any of these numbers
is found in the second column of player
card it is not subject to normal grade
changes always use the left grade D
column in these cases no matter what the
pitchers grade is occasionally pitchers
may have a C or a and B ratings always
consider these pictures of grade a
pitchers unless the a column happens to
be a base hit then use the C or B column
as the case may be for the final play
result I mean and there's literally 25
pages of this stuff that you have to
read and memorize basically to play the
game without kind of sitting there
consulting and you know that might as
well be the little small writing in the
back of a 1040 form or something like
that you know it's like it's incredibly
you know Byzantine complex tough and
there I was at 10 sitting there you know
I'd memorized it so much so that I knew
of course a grade C pitcher you look at
the left-hand column and then you
consult the right-hand column every
table vyas that's what you do why
wouldn't anybody do that so I look back
at that time and think about the amazing
you know amount of mastery I had of what
was essentially a kind of a meaningless
system right I mean I wasn't learning
you know life lessons from it really I
wasn't there was no you know moral to
the story I wasn't learning anything
that was directly useful or applicable
in my you know subsequent professional
life I did not go on to become a dice
baseball player or even a real baseball
player or a manager thankfully for the
sport of baseball but I'm absolutely
convinced that that period of kind of
three years I I was learning as much as
I was learning from anything that I was
getting in school because I was looking
at these at the little complex system of
baseball and trying to figure out what
its component parts are how it works
what's the best way to model that system
what's the best way to gauge whether
your models are accurate or not tweaking
the models learning new systems
on-the-fly exercising the mind doing the
math of dealing with all you know all
the kind of computations of these player
cards and everything and it was a mental
workout really not unlike the mental
workout that you get when you play chess
right I mean we don't get life lessons
from chess the plot of chess is
invariably pretty simplistic it always
ends the same way
there's no useful historical knowledge
imparted to you about the world from
chess but we most of us agree that
playing chess is kind of good it
exercises the minds kind of pattern
recognition skills and skills that kind
of causal relations and so on so I
thought playing those games that I was
getting the same kind of exercise and if
I was a different form and what I now
have come to believe is that that kind
of thinking which was maybe you know a
marginal bordering on mainstream you
know child pursuit at that point because
there were a lot of people playing
Dungeons and Dragons there were a lot of
people playing you know kind of dice
based military simulations like
diplomacy and things like that but it
was not something that was necessarily a
mainstream mega hit kind of part of the
culture that kind of thinking has become
much more mainstream thanks to the
proliferation of things like video games
and interactive media when you sit down
in a sense with a new piece of software
and and we all know how complex today's
software can be and you look at that
system and you learn its rules on the
fly just by exploring the system and
experimenting with it and tinkering it
and kind of building models have caused
an effect of to what clicking on this
does and what pulling down this menu
does you are exercising those same kinds
of kind of fluid on-the-spot
problem-solving skills that I was
exercising playing these games 25 years
ago or so the example that the really
brought things home to me that started
me in a way on this kind of journey was
was a few years ago I was I was on a
vacation with these nephews of mine and
I had a seven-year-old nephew at the
time and I decided to show him the video
game SimCity and this was an earlier
version of SimCity that had come out I
think it's a second last version for
those of you who haven't seen some city
basically it's a game where you get to
play a kind of a virtual Robert Moses
and build your own city a huge
metropolis on the screen and you control
everything from kind of
owning industrial areas to zoning out
residential or building highways or
putting in the infrastructure and
basically you with the beautiful thing
about the game is it you don't totally
have control over everything they
sometimes call these god games because
you can look down on the world and get
to manipulate things but what makes them
interesting is the lack of control right
you you create a highway you zone it for
residential you build a power plant you
put the infrastructure all in place and
then if you've done everything right
people start to move in to your
neighborhoods that you've built on the
screen and suddenly you'll see little
cars moving around on the screen and
then little houses start to appear and
then a factory will be built and then
suddenly you'll have a little thriving
town and if you do things right and give
them access to schools and and Parks
more people will come and then it
suddenly you'll have a little village
and then something you'll have a city
and you'll grow this thing kind of
organically on the screen it's a magical
magical game also by the way one of the
best-selling games of all time so you
know there's no violence in this game
it's really a wonderful learning
experience that also happens to be
hugely fun so I've been playing this
game you know since it first came out in
1993 the original version which did not
was not terribly complicated but it has
grown into this very complicated thing
and I was showing my nephew ed who was
seven years old and I thought well this
is this will be fun the graphics are
really cool for this so I'll take him on
a little tour of my city and I basically
took him around like I was kind of a
tour guide just showing him the
landmarks you know oh look this is my
mayor's house that I built for myself
looking out over the water there and
over here is you know where we have a
big park and this is a nice neighborhood
here were there a lot of shops I really
like that neighborhood and so I showed
him the game for about you know 20 25
minutes and then I got to this one area
that was this kind of rundown industrial
area that I had where all these
factories basically had never really
taken off and there was a lot of crime
and I was trying to deal with the crime
this was taking up a lot of my time and
so I said to him you know I'm having
trouble with this area I'm having this
kind of crime problem in this industrial
area and I can't seem to get it to work
and he looked at me and he said you know
I think you need to lower your Indust
industrial tax rates and I said in fact
that is right I probably do it would
spur development but wait a second year
7 you know where did you get this and I
had not really explained that much about
the internal dynamics of the game but in
watching you know me talk about it and
working with the assumption that he had
as a seven year old living in this
culture that
this is an interactive things and change
to variables and experiment and learn
you know from your experiments he was
already picking up this idea of lowering
industrial tax rates so he had basically
picked up something if you put him down
in an urban studies classroom at the age
of seven he would be asleep in three
seconds or crawling up the windows but
somehow in this kind of game world he
quickly kind of grasped the idea of how
the system works and was ready to kind
of get in there and get his hands dirty
he was ready to kind of experiment so
that's a very powerful mental cocktail
when you're in that kind of world you're
really doing things that I think are
enriching even if the subject matter
isn't quite as you know laudatory as as
as building a city so I'll talk a little
bit about what those kind of mental
attributes are in a second but the first
thing I want to do is at this point is
dislodge some biases many of you may
have about the importance of reading
over game-playing right most of us still
have this assumption which I think it's
partially true the kids are always
better reading a book than they are
playing a game and that there's
something just rewarding and
intellectually taxing and rigorous about
game playing about him reading already
slipping into my argument about reading
that will never really be be challenged
by the active of game playing so early
in the book I offered this kind of
thought experiment to you after quoting
a bunch of people including dr. Spock in
his baby Guide the late dr. Spock who
says you know the one thing that can be
said about video games is that they are
almost always a complete waste of time
and you know you must teach your
children to love reading and reading is
the important thing intellectually and
games are just useless so I ask you to
imagine this kind of thought experiment
which is what if games had come first
what if people had been playing and and
absorbing and you know kind of
interacting with video games for 300 to
400 years and then all of a sudden books
came along and were invented and all the
kids were into the books and the older
generation had been grown in a grown-up
playing video games would look at these
you know this is the kids today with
their books you know what would be the
kind of angry upset discouraging emails
and
and blog posts that would be written by
the older generation about about these
new books that all the kids were into
and so I wrote a little mock op-ed here
and I'll read it to you it's very
tempting to read this in kind of a
William F Buckley kind of fake British
accent but I'll try not to reading books
chronically under stimulates the senses
unlike the long-standing tradition of
game playing which engages the child in
a vivid three-dimensional world filled
with moving images and musical sound
scapes navigated and controlled with
complex muscular movements books are
simply a barren string of words on the
page only a small portion of the brain
devoted to processing written language
is activated during reading while games
engage the full range of the sensory and
motor cortices I like reading this aloud
in a bookstore people who don't actually
get the context will be walking by
hearing the thing they really should get
another author books are also tragically
isolating while games and for many years
engaged the young and complex social
relationships with their peers building
and exploring worlds together
books force the child to sequester him
or herself in a quiet space shut off
from interaction with other children
these new libraries that have arisen in
recent years to facilitate reading
activities are a frightening sight
dozens of young children normally so
vivacious and socially interactive
sitting alone in cubicles reading
silently oblivious to their peers many
children enjoy reading books of course
and no doubt some of the flights of
fancy conveyed by reading have their
escapist merits but for a sizable
percentage of the population books are
downright discriminatory the reading
craze of recent years cruelly taunts the
10 million Americans who suffer from
dyslexia a condition that didn't even
exist as a condition until printed text
came along to stigmatize its sufferers
but perhaps the most dangerous property
of these books is the fact that they
follow a fixed linear path you can't
control the narratives in any fashion
you simply sit back and have the story
dictated to you for those of us raised
on interactive narratives this property
may seem astonishing
whoo why would anyone want to embark on
an adventure
utterly choreographed by another person
but today's generation embarks on such
adventures millions of times a day this
risks instilling a general passivity in
our children making them feel as though
they're powerless to change their
circumstances reading is not an active
participatory process it is a submissive
one the book readers of the younger
generation are learning to follow the
plot instead of learning to lead so
that's now I put this up on my website
and after about six hours of being up
there I had to stop and go back and put
a disclaimer right before it appeared
Thanks warning what follows his satire I
do not actually believe these things
about books in case you noticed I write
books for a living I would not be able
to do any of the things that I do in
books without the book format I would
never attempt to make the argument of
this book in a video game for instance
but you know hopefully it gives you a
little bit of a sense of what the
discussion video game sounds like to
somebody who's actually played them when
it's coming from somebody who clearly
hasn't or in the case of many people I
think people who last played a video
game when pac-man was all the rage so
what what is what is the game experience
really like and then we try and kind of
explain a couple of things about it the
first thing that has to be said about
gaming that is really crucial and that
it's not discussed nearly enough is it
most video games today are incredibly
sometimes frustratingly difficult they
take an immense amount of patience
shockingly when you sit down and play
these games mostly the rules are not
explained to you you're dropped into a
world and you have only a basic sense of
what you can do and you don't even know
what your ultimate objective is and you
have to explore the world and learn as
you play you have to learn the rules of
the game as you're playing the game
imagine if somebody sets you down at a
chess board and said okay start playing
we'll give you feedback if you play
correctly but we're not going to tell
you what the rules are for all the
pieces so just is hard enough you know
without that but if you had an extra
layer if I have to learn how to play
chess while I'm playing chess you get
some sense of what the complexity is
like of these games so first off they're
difficult and the whole idea that you
know kids today like to go with the
cheapest easiest lowest common
denominator pleasure is completely
contradicted by the experience of gaming
if our brains really wanted to
be attracted to the cheapest pleasure
and the most instant gratification then
the history of game design would be the
history of people competing to make the
easiest game on the market in fact
people compete to make the hardest games
and the games have consistently gotten
more and more difficult over the years
because people like to be challenged
because there's pleasure and being
challenged and critically particularly
when you have an interactive form that
can reward success when you when you
finally achieve it it's a very
intoxicating mix two people a second
point about these games they involve at
every point decision-making at every
single moment in a game you're sitting
there evaluating what's in front of you
evaluating what's happened in the past
evaluating the decisions that you've
made and the objectives that you have in
front of you and based on that mix of
information you are making a snap
decision about what to do next
whether it's explore this way whether
it's sometimes shooting at something
whether it's building industrial zone
zoning areas or whether it's doing any
number of things that these games can do
you're making decisions at every turn
whatever else you say about the merits
of reading whatever else you might say
about the merits of television whatever
else you might say about the merits of
film on some basic level you do not make
decisions when you read or you watch a
movie or you watch television show you
know you use your imagination of ways
you know a book you know I'll say it a
million times here if you need me to say
it books are fantastic novels are
incredible things nonfiction popular
nonfiction is a wonderful thing all
these things are great but you don't
really make active decisions when you're
reading something you you are on some
level following somebody else's
decisions that they've made in crafting
the book for you in games that the the
idea of decision making is not a
metaphor it's an active thing that you
are constantly doing and there is no
more I think elemental component of
intelligence and your ability to assess
what's in front of you all the variables
going on and make the decision about the
proper course to follow that's that's a
core component of what it means to be
smart games are exercising that in a way
that that all media up to this point has
not even come close to two other points
about it there's something I call in the
book probing and probing is this process
where you're looking at the system and
you're trying to figure out in a sense
these rules you're trying to figure out
the physics of the world if I jump here
will I land on the other
I really fall down in the ravine you're
trying to figure out what the other
characters are doing what their
relationships are to you what secrets
they may have where the puzzles are and
you do that basically by this method of
going into the world exploring around
building a hypothesis about how one part
of the world works trying that
hypothesis out and if it works
proceeding with that is an accepted idea
or if it doesn't work going back and
trying again and working on another idea
in other words what the gamers are doing
is what we also call the scientific
method they're constantly probing this
world looking for kind of working
hypotheses about how the world works and
building on those ideas if they turn out
to be fruitful and if they don't they go
back and they try it again again that's
something you know you don't do in a
book for all the virtues of reading and
finally there's something I call
telescopic thinking which is in a game
the best way to capture this is to is to
freeze somebody in the middle of a
complicated game in the book I talk
about a game called Zelda which is
played by eight-year-olds and 38
year-olds and everybody in between and
it's a kind of you know classic rescue
the princess kind of story where you
have to go on a mission and you go
through all these kind of tests and if
you if you freeze somebody kind of 20
hours into a game basically like that
that takes about 40 hours to play and
ask them what are your objectives what
are you working on in your mind what are
you thinking your goals are at this
particular point what you'll end up
getting I think I can just kind of show
it to you if you if you have the book in
front of you it's on page 52 but I
summarized basically about half of the
kind of active objectives in your head
at one point in about hour 20 in the
game Zelda and it sounds like this to
locate you have to locate these items to
locate the items you need the pearl of
DIN from the Islanders to get this you
need to help them solve their problem to
do this you need to cheer up the prince
to do this you need to get a letter from
the girl to do this you need to find the
girl in the village once you get the
letter to the prints you must now
befriend the prince do to do this you
need to get at the top of dragon risk
mountain to do this you must get to the
other side of the gorge etc etc etc goes
on from here to here and then if I've
actually printed the whole thing it
would have gone on another equally that
long for another you know two pages or
so that's just a snapshot of basically
an hour's worth of play
and what's important about this is that
it's nested right so you can't just do
anything you want you have objectives
but certain objectives are more
important than others and certain
objectives have to be kind of played out
in order in sequence but you don't know
what the sequence is you have to figure
out what the sequence is and then figure
out what the priorities are and then
start executing these objectives as
you're playing so what you have to do is
have this what I described is kind of a
telescopic way of thinking where you
have to have a long distance view but
but all the objectives kind of
collapsing in on themselves so that you
have this kind of nested way of thinking
well I have to do this first but then
I'll do that and once I've done those
two things I'll be able to do this other
thing which will lead me to my ultimate
goal which is this which will then start
a whole new adventure in the next hour
of this game now that by the way is how
we think all the time in real life right
this is what we think about when we're
sitting at the office we think okay I
have to write this memo short term so
that I can get this thing out the door
so that we can close down that project
so that I can get that raise so that I
can buy that new house so that I can be
happy or whatever the list is in your
head it's that kind of nested telescopic
thinking that's crucial to just being
successful and and being smart and
engaged in the world video games again
are exercising that kind of power
they're doing it in a way that's kind of
fanciful and made up of cartoon
characters and the content isn't all
that interesting of the games but the
mental work is just as the content of
chess isn't all that interesting the
content of calculus on some level isn't
all that interesting but we accept the
idea that it's good for kids in school
to exercise their mind by doing calculus
even though we agree that all of us
agree the 99% of the kids who learn
calculus will never actually use it in
any clear direct way when they become
grownups but there's something good
about that kind of exercise that we
value so that's what they're getting
some games now let me move on a little
bit and talk about the television
section and then briefly touch on on why
we think why I think this is happening
and then open it up for you guys to
shoot down my theory and cause me to
crawl home and cry myself to sleep it's
funny people have two very different
responses look some people are shocked
and an appalled that I would defend
video games but do admit the television
seems to be getting smarter and then
some people are totally by the video
games argument but are shocked and
appalled that I would ever do
and television so I'm offending
everybody inside the different ways it's
good it's a good sign
with television what I think is actually
happening is is not so much that the
television shows today are really
driving the kind of sharpening of the
mind that I think the interactive media
the games are I think in a sense
television is kind of playing catch-up
and that what they've learned is that
there are all these kids out there who
have grown up playing these incredibly
complicated video games and have come to
expect that their entertainment will
challenge them mentally and so when you
sit those kids down in front of Three's
Company or Laverne and Shirley they're
going to be bored because they expect
more intrigue they expect more challenge
they expect more kind of mental juggling
that you have to do as part of the
entertainment so what I try to look at
in the book was the history of the last
30 years viewed from this same angle of
how much cognitive work do you have to
do to make sense of your average
television show and I looked at a couple
of different factors the first is this
property of multiple narrative lines so
how much had cell haven't changed in
terms of the number of plots that your
average episode will throw at you in the
old days of TV basically you would have
one episode equals pretty much one plot
with maybe one minor subplot so you
would sit down for your 30 minutes or
your hour and you would be basically
focused on one major question there's
been a burglary
who's the who actually did it we have to
figure it out there's a crime scene we
have to solve the mystery and that's
what we're focused on and then in 1981
with some precedent and soap operas and
a few other things that the book gets
into a show came out the most you
probably remember called Hill Street
Blues which was the the first mainstream
kind of serious drama on network
television to do really fully
multi-threaded as they call it narrative
where there would be five or six
sometimes even more separate narratives
woven through an episode of Hill Street
Blues and I actually have little charts
in the book that show you visually in a
sense what it looks like but I had a lot
of fun creating and hill street came out
and it was literally too difficult for
the audience of the day to understand it
they mean this is this is an absolute
proven fact they ran a pilot everybody
plained it was too complicated it went
on the air it had incredible reviews it
was in a great position on network on
NBC's primetime schedule though they did
move it around a little bit and despite
all that great press it basically
finished I think 71 out of 73 in the
Nielsen's for the year when it was very
close to dead last and everybody was
complaining right left that we just
can't follow all these plots our brains
just get distracted by all these
different interactions we really prefer
their shows where there's one thing
going on because it's too hard to keep
track of all these things
fast forward 25 years or so and there's
a whole host of shows everything from
you know Sopranos to the wire and six
feet under on HBO to alias to a 24
apparently to Desperate Housewives so
that I haven't seen Desperate Housewives
but apparently it has a lot of this kind
of multiple threading as well - the
reality shows which are you know
survivor and The Apprentice have
multiple lines of kind of interactions
between all the different characters you
often will have 15 characters
interacting in many different ways
all of these shows are much more
complicated than Hill Street Blues was
and they actually are more complicated
in other ways in the sense that they're
constantly referencing things that
happen you know find episode of The
Sopranos will make a reference to
something that happened five episodes
ago without doing a lot of hand-holding
it won't explain to you what happened
they won't have flashbacks they'll just
assume that you're paying attention and
remember something that happened five
weeks ago so all these shows are
significantly more complicated than Hill
Street was and yet they are all you know
Nielsen top 20 shows apprentice Brando's
even though it's on HBO is a huge hit
regularly out drawers and networks so
something has happened in our mind over
those 25 years that we've gone from
being a you know a nation of people is
that I can't follow all these plots it's
over you know I'm shorting out here due
to our being much more comfortable with
that and more comfortable being
challenged by these multiple plots so
that's that's one major change now
another one is social networks which is
kind of a flip side of the same same
kind of argument one of the things that
we do this came out of my last book mine
wide open which looked at brain science
and its ability to come teach you about
yourself in your own lives now one of
the things that recent brain science has
explained to us is that our ability to
map social networks of people
is one of our great and eight strengths
as human beings we have dedicated kind
of circuitry in our brains that is very
good at keeping kind of networks of
social social groups alive in our heads
and keeping track of all the kind of
soap-opera questions of who's getting
along with who and who's not who's
feuding with who and who your allies are
and who's over there is manipulating who
so that's an that kind of social
intelligence we know if you've ever read
a book like emotional intelligence or
emotional IQ you know that that kind of
social intelligence is hugely predictive
of your real-world success you know it
as predictive as your you know ability
to score well in the SATs when you go
into the office environment when you're
you know working through academia or
you're trying to do anything
professionally where you're dealing with
large groups of people and your
performance is related to your ability
to kind of manage all those
relationships if you have social IQ if
you are good at mapping social networks
and keeping track of all the different
relationships around you you will
perform much better in that environment
so that's a real form of intelligence
that we've only begun to appreciate
through some of the you know kind of
recent cognitive science research into
the emotions and kind of social IQ now
what I'm arguing is that another trend
that you can see as part of the sleeper
curve is the trend towards increased
social dramatic trend towards increased
social network complexity in television
shows so again I think you can almost
see this from far away if you have the
book so I feel like I'm teaching a class
now everybody turn to page this is this
technique that I have to get people to
pick up the book and have it in their
hand so they're more likely to buy it
later this on page 110 this does you can
see it this is a map of the social
network of an episode of Dallas from
1978 exactly it's actually episode 8
from season 1 of jalous and it's
basically about 10 characters and the
little lines connecting them are showing
you these are relationships that you
need to understand to make sense of the
episode so you have to understand that
Bobby and jr. are brothers for instance
that's a basic relationship and in this
episode you have to understand that
they're feuding over which one is going
to have a baby first and please their
family patriarch jock I've kind of
outlined certain they're like four major
relationships that are central to the
plot and then they're about 10 or 12
that are kind of peripheral but that are
that are useful in understanding the
narrative now this is the social network
that you need to keep track in your head
to understand a single episode of the
show 24 they very much hit show 24 and
there are 31 I think characters in this
episode and many many multiple lines of
connection between them that you have to
kind of chart in your head and in fact
they're more lines here because it's a
mole plot where you're worried about you
know who the mole is in the in the
intelligence unit and so you're
constantly thinking about relationships
that the show actually hasn't spelled
out specifically because you're like
it's that person the mole maybe that
person is a mole or are they related to
this other person I don't know so so
it's actually even more complicated than
that so it's literally about three times
as complex a network and this is
something that we sit down and watch
happily every day we eat it up we think
it's you know really challenging and
interesting and it's grown that much
more complicated and social network
mapping is empirically an important part
of being a smart person so on some level
I'm arguing you are exercising your
social network mapping skills when you
choose to watch a show like 24 rather
than a show like Dallas now you can
absolutely exercise your social network
mapping skills by reading a complex
social network that's represented in the
form of a novel as well but I'm talking
about the comparative trends in society
and 30 years ago we were all watching
Dallas now we're all watching 24 and 24
is much richer and more challenging in
this particular respect I'll save the
reality TV stuff but if people want to
ask me about that concept that's one of
the things that people feel strongly
about let me move on and and conclude by
saying a couple of things about why I
think this is happening and then we can
open it up to questions the first thing
that's important to debunk I think with
this is the idea that I alluded to
earlier that that we all have kind of
intrinsically slacker brains that we
really want on some level the cheapest
pleasure the the most instant
gratification and then we seek out
things that won't challenge us and I
believe that that's wrong I believe that
the reason why for some part of the
history of kind of 20th century pop
culture we were drawn towards kind of
cheap pleasures is because the
technology
she was pushing us in that way less our
own appetites there's a great quote here
from an NBC executive and Paul Klein who
was describing the philosophy at Dennis
a NBC or ABC NBC he was describing the
philosophy at NBC kind of in the late
70s in many ways it's kind of the nadir
of of television programming I would
argue if you're talking about what
happens when you have three big networks
and people don't have any choices and
they don't have the internet and they
don't really have video games and so
basically their choices they can read a
book or they can watch television and
there are only three or four things on
TV at any given time and so and there's
no way to kind of pause or rewind or do
anything else you know we don't have
VCRs at that point so basically the
network's at that point with television
kind of had people captive if they were
going to watch something they basically
had very few options and so they
developed a philosophy that this guy
Paul Klein dubbed the theory of least
objectionable programming and he was
saying if somebody who put stuff on the
air that the what he was trying to do is
just make sure that whatever he was
putting on was the least objectionable
and that would keep him at his you know
30% share of the market so this is a
quote from his speech that he gave this
is an amazingly evil speech I think we
all started equally all three networks
then we can add to that by our
competitors failure they become
objectionable too so people turn to us
if we're less objectionable or we could
lose audience by inserting little tricks
that caused the loss of an audience
thought that's tune-out education to
announce definitely tuned out you know
melodrama is good you know a little tear
here and there a little morality tale
that's good positive that's least
objectionable it's my job to keep my 32%
not to cause any tuna tune out a priori
in terms of ads or concepts to make sure
there's no tune out in the show's Visa
Visa Visa Visa Competition I like the
visa fee in the a priori so the idea is
let's just not offend anybody and we'll
just we'll stay where we are and that'll
be good let's not challenge anybody's
brain at all now compare that to what's
happened and this sketch to the to the
second force so I think is driving the
sleeper curve and that is that almost
all the technologies of media that have
liberated so much really in the last 30
years you think of all the things that
we've added to the repertoire almost all
of them have been in one form or another
technologies of repetition that enable
you to kind of stop and rewind and watch
something again or watch a whole episode
and then go back and watch it again
starting with the VCR obviously you
could either watch the movie and rewind
it and watch the movie again or you
could tape things on TV and pause it or
watch it later or watch it six times if
you wanted and then we had DVDs come
along and you could watch you could buy
a movie and you could watch it 17 times
if you wanted and suddenly television
shows were coming out on DVD and you
could watch a whole season even though
you'd left it behind many many years ago
on the network's syndication even before
that became a huge money maker in the
business so you know the Seinfeld
creators you know made their vast
fortunes not from actually you know the
first run of their shows but from the
after market deals when they sold their
shows into syndication so that they
would live on forever in the cable
universe so that's where the money was
and then you have things like TiVo now
of course and video on-demand and even
people now downloading you know
digitized television shows and sharing
them illegally on the Internet all of
these things enable you to watch things
multiple times if they're at all
challenging you can pause and rewind and
figure out more about them and what they
do is they create an economic incentive
in the market to create programming that
improves on repeat viewings and that is
a fundamental shift from that era of
least objectionable programming I'll
call it most repeatable programming the
shows that prosper in this environment
are the shows that don't get incredibly
annoying and dull the third time you see
them Seinfeld and The Simpsons have
ruled the syndication airwaves partially
because you can watch The Simpsons four
times and still catch new little things
there are a million little subtle
references to go on in that show that
you can watch a new episode or episode
you've already seen three times and folk
I never got the Friday the 13th
reference there in that scene oh that's
a Citizen Kane thing but wait that's a
reference to that first season episode
we're sort so so the economic model
encourages complexity encourages
challenge it encourages all the things
that Paul Kline thought were were a
threat to his market share back in 1980
and a final thing that I'll add to this
mix is the effect that the internet has
had
on these shows if you go to the online
kind of fan sites and discussion forums
for any of these hyper complex shows if
you go and and see The Sopranos fan site
or the 24 fan site or lost
the show now that's that's such a rage
you'll find you know thousands and
thousands of virtual pages of people
annotating every single little moment of
these shows and explaining why this
character did this and explaining why
this was the reference to season 2 and
basically because that realm of
commentary is available now the shows
can get more complicated because they
know that if their audience gets lost
they can not only see it again
but they can also go back and look
online and figure out oh that's why that
guy killed that guy in Sweden - I didn't
understand what that was now now it
makes sense to me so there's an attempt
a whole support network for the for the
new complexity of the media because
because the Internet has created these
forms and so all of those things create
a kind of a positive feedback loop or
suddenly their rewards and opportunity
for more complicated shows people get
used to the shows being more complicated
they come to expect that rather than you
know your average tony danza sitcom that
we've been kind of trained on that i
grew up on and you end up getting this
rising curve towards more complexity
that's the story of the sleeper curve
that's the story that I try and tell in
the book and that's what I hope you'll
you'll get to read if you get a chance
to read the book so thank you for
listening to me I think we have like
what do you think 5-10 minutes okay
that's let's go ahead and fire some
questions and Stephen wants me first
yes thank you very much your thesis
certainly is an excellent prescription
for preventing boredom exercising the
mind it's it it's consistent with the
American ideology of trying to enjoy
every moment as one of complete novelty
Americans have a very short attention
span I can so what you're exercising is
your intelligence and your imagination
but
they on the negative side it would
appear that memory is being neglected
the advantage of reading is that you you
can memorize what you read then you
reflect upon it which is a hallmark of
philosophy and you can make a decision
whether to accept or reject whatever you
read so but it's it's also consistent
with the human evolutionary theory that
we are evolving toward greater degrees
of complexity especially within the
brain and that's thank you that's that's
a great point and I and III agree with
what you're saying let me say a couple
let me explain why I agree with it
because it might seem to contradict in
some ways without what I've been arguing
the first is there's a very specific
kind of tactical thing that I'm trying
to do with this book which is to engage
in the debate that's happening right now
and point out this what I see is a very
clear positive thing that is happening
because there's very little talk about
any positive thing happening so it may
well be that as a society or as
individuals we decide that I'm right and
that we are getting these kind of
problem-solving upgrades and our ability
to kind of do these this kind of fluid
intelligence is in fact improving thanks
to the popular culture but that it's
still not entirely made up for the fact
that we're losing the kind of historical
thinking and the philosophical thinking
or in another argument that the morality
is so bad or the violence is so bad that
it's not making up for the fact that
we're getting these cognitive upgrades
and in the way that I'm describing the
book if that's the case that's fine I
don't necessarily think that I agree
with that argument I think on the whole
probably things are getting better on
average but I'll accept somebody who
looks at it honestly and says yes you're
right about the Sleeper curve but there
are these other costs and we have to
factor those in I'm happy with that the
problem is the state of the debate now
is we're all just getting stupider and
and everything is going to dumb down and
the television has never been more crude
and the video games are a total waste of
time so I'm trying to do something
tactical and that does mean you know
emphasizing certain things over others
you know as as I'm sure you know when
you write books and kind of focus ways
and you're trying to emphasize a certain
point I personally my background I spent
five years all of a dissertation in
England century literature and in grad
school and I spent you know the time
leading up to my orals reading about you
know 75 80 19th century novels and the
time I spent living in that world is one
of the most amazing kind of richest
experiences of my life and it is a kind
of cultural experience that you you will
never get out of a video game but so I
sense the the loss that comes from those
types of experiences becoming less
dominant in the society but the flip
side of that is that people still do
read novels you know it's not as if that
these older forms are completely going
away it's just the balance the ratio is
McLuhan talked about it's changing
someone and so you know maybe the thing
to do is to focus as a society and in
our education system or as parents and
recognize well our kids are getting
quite smart in terms of problem solving
and the things that might show up on an
IQ test but we really need to emphasize
these other things because that's what
they're not getting from the pop culture
and that's and that's the kind of
balancing act I think we need to do yes
looking at these at these graphs of the
complexity of POD structures and
television shows and so forth and in
listening to your comments about
complexity I know that there's a comment
you made earlier there's there's a
contradiction in your there's a
contradiction in this basic scheme that
I think shows a central flaw in your
argument which is the trade-off between
between formal mental operations and
content you yourself admitted that
trade-off and the fact of the matter is
is that it really doesn't matter how
complex these plots have become how much
information we can keep track of because
basically it's still crap and the
characters are bad the ideas are bad the
concepts are shallow and and it's
complexity without meaning without
content or depth and actually if you
look at television although I think that
some of the more recent
shows have been good ones in Seinfeld
insight and Simpsons I think about two
of the only three or four decent things
that there have been in the past 20
years
I think that we've lost quite a bit and
if you look at the shows that I grew up
in the early 60s for all the limitations
of censorship and so forth in fact some
of them are much better written and the
acting was better and the drama was
better for example I think the best
written show of all time was route 66
which was the most literate and had the
most emotional depth and character
development and why is this because the
people in those days did not grow up
watching television and then they didn't
they grew up reading books or and they
had real life experiences and when you
have the experience both of leading real
life and you have the experience of
literacy and reflection
you have you have depth and you have
content if you only grew up watching TV
and then you and then you and then you
get a degree you know in Media Studies
and think you can you have something to
say about anything you're going to show
how shallow and pointless your life and
your and your mind actually is so I find
that your argument has a fundamental
flaw in it that is the increase in our
ability to process formal operations
basically does nothing to counteract the
lack of critical ability the lack of
criticizing the society in which we live
in the assumptions under which we live
and develop critical thought and develop
ourselves and historically that has only
been done by by one method which is the
development of literacy too and that's
what's lifted people out of poverty and
hopelessness and other things and and
given people the capacity to critically
reflect on their lives as literacy and
not just this other stuff well it's a
lot of things respond to I would say
first off that I would challenge all of
you to go back and look at the programs
they were on the air not in the kind of
early golden age of television of the
50s and the early 60s when it was really
kind of porting over kind of the
Broadway mentality and when it was
targeting a much smaller audience and
really look at the programs from 19 you
know 65 to 1985 and look at the audience
and go back and watch the knick at night
and not just look at all in the family
or Mary Tyler Moore but look at the
broad spectrum of those shows and my
personal feeling and the belief of a lot
of television critics who spent a lot of
time
dealing with content in addition to the
kind of formal questions I raise a lot
of people just flat-out disagree with
what you're saying and believe that
there has been in fact you know a height
of kind of complexity and show like er
the West Wing The Sopranos Six Feet
Under
that was never visible in those shows in
those days and in fact the shows have
gotten much more cinematic and and
complex in their storytelling these are
stories that go on for a hundred hours
if you look at them over the course of
their their you know multiple seasons
it's a storytelling form that chip
McGrath the old New York Times Book
Review editors compared to basically
saying that this is our kind of modern
serial triple-decker novel based on the
19th century that there is the kind of
depth that you claim it's not there as
far as literacy goes I mean I have
nothing I absolutely believed in the
importance of literacy I have nothing to
complain about that I just think that
that media literacy is an important part
of functioning in this world and offers
many opportunities that traditional
literacy can only you know partially get
to you don't get decision-making from
traditional literacy in the same way
that you can get from the interactive
media so and there's there is very
little evidence that we are losing our
critical faculties our SAT scores are up
both for math and verbal IQ scores are
dramatically up the Society has never
been less violent the generation raised
on television video games is out there
creating you know you've never seen more
20-somethings central to the u.s.
economy than you have with the creation
of companies like Yahoo and Google and
Amazon and so it's so in force so forth
like that
so the overall health of the generation
raised on these things I don't see any
evidence that there is in fact a problem
to be worried about and in fact when you
look at the forms you find that they
have a lot of rewards that that simply
haven't been acknowledged because we
don't have the language yet to describe
them so I respectfully disagree if I can
just follow up on the first two people
the first question relates to
imagination because I believe that when
you read a book particularly a good
novel you're actually creating the
pictures in your head the characters you
know the second is when you play video
games a lot of attention is made to the
speed of the decision rather than the
thoughtfulness of decision so we now
have a generation that make wrong
decisions quickly and if it's right is
good luck if it isn't it isn't and I
think the last and I sometimes think the
most
important point of all is it if you've
mentioned the SATs in the new SAT it's
now necessary to teach people how to
write essays because that now is taken
off and this now becomes a new art and
art which would never be new had it been
retained instead of being a
multiple-choice alternative right right
well let me make it very clear again I
think particularly imagination is a
wonderful faculty and it is one of the
things that you get from reading that
you don't get from these other forms in
quite the same way and that's why I
support the continuing of books being
read but I guess I I disagree and I
would stress again that there is a
there's a faulty stereotype about the
speed of decision-making in the game
world and this idea that which was which
was brought up before this idea that
were we're all moving towards these kind
of instant snap judgments and this kind
of accelerated pace and in fact the game
playing rhythm for many of these games
is quite slow and the thinking process
that you have to have is I need to think
forward 20 hours and think about what
the consequences are in this world 20
hours from now and what this will mean
in this particular world and I have to
balance all those things in my head and
it's not just oh it's coming in here I
have to shoot oh it's coming here I have
to shoot that's the kind of stereotype
but most of the games are about longer
chains of kind of causal relationships
and so there is a lot more patience
involved there's a lot of patience I
mean think of you know the kind of
higher end of the kind of thinking that
you do in a video game is programming
now it's another Faculty of something
that you know it's much more common
there many more teenage you know
computer programmers and there were 20
or 30 years ago and in fact the logic of
games was quite for kind of obvious
reasons connected to the logic of
computer programming and computer
programming takes an immense amount of
patience it takes an immense amount of
logic skills and it takes an immense
amount of kind of long-term thinking
I've got a local objective but I have to
think about the macro needs of the
program and how it can combine those two
things and so that that's the kind of
thinking that I think is really being
encouraged in the society and it's not
again the only kind of thinking but it
but it's one that has has real world
value and applicability and if you can
use schools to
and teach people to write essays they're
writing a lot more than they used to
because of email and the internet and
the interactive kind of text of of that
world but teach them to write essays and
give them a sense of history in the
school you can take these fabulous
logical skills and combine them with
with traditional education and you've
got a really great cocktail but right
now nobody's even acknowledging the
logic skills and that's and that's what
I'm trying to do yeah
all right coming from that generation um
I had a quick question one in response
to the other questions well I was just
kinda have you ever heard of Final
Fantasy mm-hmm right now like I would
like to read a lot so I like to read
specifically the Russian authors like
Dostoyevsky and I also like philosophy a
lot and since they don't have TV I can't
respond to the whole TV question but I
can respond to the movie because I like
movies and I like videogames and the
most recent one of the most recent Final
Fantasy's deals a lot with Baudelaires
uh some okra and all these things like
that sort of dream state versus
non-state versus what is reality versus
not reality and Dass and also asking all
these writers all do that too my
question for you however is that I mean
it seems though yes they are becoming
more complicating things of that circus
you have movies like The Matrix at least
the first one yeah
which was more complicated then you have
this movie crash which deals a lot with
emotions and things of that sort and
gets more real and gritty but my
question is I've noticed also in
literature more recently that there are
more ideas and less description of
scenes like specifically is focusing on
like descriptions of the house things of
that sort is more focused on ideas and
like moving in like plot movements and
things of that so I was just warning if
you would seen some cons similar tell me
again what you what you're saying that
the ship from ia is like a like [ __ ] no
I'm saying like I seem shift to ideas
from descriptions like right like when
I'm reading Dostoyevsky and things of
that sort you see a lot more description
on scenes
I mean it's moving that direction but
it's still moving in like some of the
ideas and things of that sort but you
have a lot of description of scenes
rooms things like that versus now I'm
reading the new author who wrote that
thingy I can't remember that name right
ah but no way so well you're saying is
there it's a move away from kind of
description of the world towards kind of
the life of the mind kind of internal
monologues and things like that that's
interesting I haven't I haven't noticed
that I mean there's a tradition you know
if that's happening it's interesting
because it's repeating in a sense a
tradition a shift that happened around
the turn of the century kind of the Raj
modernism where there was a kind of a
movement towards a kind of the interior
landscape of the subject and their
appraisal of the outside world and so
you have Henry James and you had Proust
and you had stream-of-consciousness and
Joyce and Ulysses and so you moved away
from kind of describing you know Dickens
for instance you know or Eliot are all
really much more about kind of the
external actions of characters and and
their effect on the world
you rarely ever get inside the head of a
Dickens character in the way that you
get inside the heads of Henry James so
it may be that we then went through a
phase of you know kind of post-modernism
where we were playing and riffing on the
text and now we're going back into
another kind of internal world that I
haven't necessarily seen that okay maybe
one more question okay going to with
regard to games let me throw you a
softball great okay
always appreciate that you argue that
our minds are being made sharper but did
the age group that you talked about is
usually the younger folks did you give
any thought to the value of games and
pot perhaps the use by older folks to
keep the aging the aging mind you know
keeping us going a little bit there is a
yeah that I haven't actually thought
about it but maybe that's a sequel that
I could I can get back I didn't know
it's a it's a really interesting because
people do really talk about they use
that kind of exercise language that I
use in the book you know you need you
know kinda mental calisthenics as well
as
one's to kind of keep your mind healthy
and and that apparently can be helpful
in dealing with Alzheimer's and things
like that so so there may well be a
prescription of videogames that we may
read too loud - to our seniors that is
okay okay good
all right it's called everything bad is
good